be like who's going to lend money to
jurisdictions if a Big Rich place like
Chicago or Illinois can't make it can't
make its obligation meet its obligations
and so these are really difficult
choices and so I have some ideas about
things we could do to make the problem
better but it's worth thinking about
what you would do I mean one of the
things I found during the covid period
is there was a lot of intense arguing
arguing about what the federal
government should be of a state
bankruptcy law should we offer all of
this Aid is it a blue State bailout is a
red State bailout
um and I found that the people talking
about this really didn't take the time
to realize how hard a set of choices
were facing the government it was just a
lot of yelling
thank you
[Music]
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast a very smart man yeah law school
professor and author of in a bad State
responding to State and local budget
crises David Schleicher welcome David
thank you so much for having me so
congrats on this book
um some people look at this and be like
what state and local budget crises are
those a thing uh and there was a period
when everyone thought they were going to
be a big thing postcovid where kovitz
shut the economies down and I was seeing
the headlines be like hey if the these
local governments have to fire a bunch
of people you're gonna have a lot more
fired people uh and then the feds came
through in a very very big way uh the
cares act I think it's about five
trillion dollars of uh stimulus in total
uh hundreds of billions of which went to
State and local governments so all is
okay right
yeah so it's I mean the answer is in
some ways for a little while the answer
was yeah so state and local budgets have
been in better shape for the last couple
of years they've been maybe in any point
in American history or at least uh
certainly they've been as as good
um between the fact that the economy
never really got as bad as people
expected and particularly high-end
wealth which is State local budgets that
are dependent on high-end income taxes
and capital gains taxes did very well
and then the other boatloads of money
that the federal government gave State
local budgets were in really strong
shape but right now we're seeing an end
to that Federal money that might have
been is drying up some of it was even
pulled back in the debt limit deal and
we're seeing
um revenues starting to fall and so
you're starting to see projected budgets
budget deficits in uh you know
California and Illinois and New York and
New York City
um uh and what we're gonna see is how
many jurisdictions use the boom times
to save and to fundamentally reform
their budget so they'd be healthy going
forward
um and which ones uh kind of played
Brewster's Millions with the money just
got it and spent it as quickly as they
could yeah so just because you you write
up some examples how many did this rainy
day fund thing uh and you have an
example or two and then how many were
like screw it this money spigot will go
forever let's spend spend spend well so
I mean it's a little against largely a
lot of jurisdictions save money in the
rain day funds but the real question is
did they create liabilities going
forward this can be hard for them to
they're gonna be hard for them to
reverse and so you see places that um
when you hire a bunch of new workers
it's really hard to fire them the next
year or if you cut taxes people are
going to be really unhappy about the
taxes being cut going forward and so the
real problems are not nearly the savings
but it's the creation of liabilities
going forward and so Community funds are
are pretty healthy at the moment on
average across jurisdictions
and yet for whatever reason it feels
like there there's another shoe to drop
now one of the major things that you see
in headlines and you and I are in New
York is that commercial real estate is
not faring very well uh Barbara Corcoran
of Shark Tank who's a real estate expert
said uh that Midtown commercial
buildings are 50 occupied and this is
like you know at this point like years
after reopening uh my like you might
even say that this most major companies
have already come down with various
policies
um so it's not like 50 with a giant up
Arrow attached to it necessarily I mean
it rebounded from near zero to fifty
percent but these buildings aren't
viable at 50 occupancy no I mean proper
commercial property values are falling
and going to keep falling um at least
for the shorter medium term
um and that has pretty big dramatic
that's pretty big implications for local
government budgets in that govern
downtown pounds but for a couple of
reasons one is that commercial property
tax rates are generally higher than
residential property rate tax rates
because
um offices don't vote but people do
um uh and uh secondly it's concurs in
disruptions
um and also will reduce I mean the
working from home which results Liberty
sales tax revenue because people aren't
going to the office then you know
they're not buying buying lunch or
whatever
um and maybe the government's the type
of governments that are most directly
affected are not even the ones that are
direct directly taxing commercial
property taxes but uh property but our
Transit agencies trans agencies have
lost enormous amounts of Revenue
um through because people just aren't
riding trains because they're not
commuting quite as much or the commuting
rates are fun and while New York is bad
it's not the one that's worst off San
Francisco it the commercial the the
office utilization in San Francisco is
really really really really low
um and so uh some of this will shake out
over time which is as price full
you'll get new tenants in different
types of tenants will emerge hopefully
although it doesn't it's actually much
harder than people think you'll see some
some residential conversions
um but um it's going to create pretty
big revenue losses in the short and
medium term for cities and maybe even
longer than that yeah so let's press on
the residential conversions so it turns
out it's very very hard to turn an
office building into an apartment
building and some of the Practical
problems are Plumbing so think about
your average office building it's got uh
one restroom two restrooms three
restrooms and then when when it's time
to put in apartments like everyone wants
a restroom so you know like that's a big
problem there are a lot of interior
spaces that might not have Windows which
is a No-No for a lot of Apartments
kitchens the same Jam elevators the
elevators are often not built to the
same specifications they're required for
residential building you've got a lot of
building code problems for residential
conversions it's just not happening I
mean and then on top of it
um you need
um a lot of zoning changes and some in
New York you need some State Law changes
it's office conversion residential
office conversion is really really hard
it was okay in some of the older
buildings downtown in New York so in the
financial districts the buildings were
built differently than modern Office
Buildings
um but you know it's really hard to see
uh residential diversions a lot of the
buildings if they're going to become
residential are gonna have to be knocked
down yeah and then at that point it's
not much of a conversion you're like hey
let's build an apartment building yeah I
I have been in the downtown uh office
buildings that have been converted and
some of them are very nice uh but
they're still also funky like all the
dimensions are funky yeah I completely
agree it's um it's uh it's um it's it's
you can see people sometimes like funky
like it's like Lofts or whatever they
have a little bit of that feel to them
um it's something it's like a unique
space but it is um it's not going to be
a massive source of housing particularly
because the state and city are going to
require uh if they ever do allow this
they're going to require a good amount
of the apartments that are created to be
uh deed restricted affordable
um or red restricted and uh the result
will be that the the economics of it
doesn't work out even if you can
overcome some of the building code
changes and so I don't think there's any
real uh realistic opportunities for
residential conversions particularly in
New York in again in the shorter median
term unless the politics exchange is
pretty substantially yeah and you
mentioned San Francisco which has the
these problems uh revved up even higher
perhaps I mean there there are very
large Office Buildings
um you're saying that their occupancy is
lower than 50 which wouldn't surprise
too much slower yeah San Francisco is
the lowest of any downtown
so is that like 20 25 yeah something
like that I don't have the number of
them but something it's really loud uh
and what's interesting is both New York
and San Francisco these buildings were
premium priced before I mean they could
command crazy uh rents and then now they
can rent it for any level uh well I mean
it's unclear whether they can rent a
privilege so there's been some some the
the price Discovery has been slow in
this area and there's some reasons you
might imagine something about their
contracts the things that there's been
some lack of desire to take losses which
may affect the banks and there's a
couple of things going on
um but it has been a whether they're
permanently useless
um or temporary useless or just uh in
some kind of stasis due to some kind of
difficulty working out contracts is a
little hard to say
um it's you're right is in that we don't
know what the correct price level is and
there are a lot of incentives in place
for them not to rent something for a
song because then everyone else in the
building's like wait what they're
getting it for a song and then your
creditors are like wait what you're
renting it for that level if you rented
at that level you can never pay us back
uh and and so there are a lot of folks
who are probably
um Frozen in place yeah it's I mean it's
not the problem is in some ways pretty
similar to the problem we've seen in New
York for a while about
um about uh retail vacancies just like
retail space is really expensive in New
York why was it the case that there were
so many retail vacancies even before
covet and the answer was like there was
a lot of difficulties with contracts and
pricing in the way that you described
and so it's a uh it's a it's a we we
might need legal interventions of other
sorts to encourage the market to shake
out a little better yeah the average uh
retail lease is probably something like
four or five years and a lot of folks
aren't able to make that kind of
commitment this will have some effect on
uh commercial property tax revenue going
forward which will be a big problem and
please like New York are obviously very
dependent on commercial property taxes
but so are almost all downtowns
um and you're seeing you know
differential problems across
jurisdictions your office office uptake
in southern jurisdictions is much higher
than it is in uh in New York and San
Francisco but it's a problem everywhere
that you're seeing decline in commercial
property values and that is particularly
a fiscal problem because they're
generally taxed at higher rates
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by expressvpn
in a tough economy you're looking for
ways to save money and you know a sneaky
way you can do it expressvpn now you're
asking yourself how is that possible
doesn't expressvpn cost money it does
cost less than seven dollars a month but
it can help you unlock content that will
save you money for days and days what do
I mean for example let's say I'm a Duran
Duran fan which I am I want to watch the
concert movie of Duran Duran but it is
not available on Netflix in the US
however with expressvpn I can just beam
myself into the UK click on Netflix and
voila
Duran Duran and a bunch of other content
I could not have gotten any other way
it's a no-brainer if you want to
preserve your own data from the big tech
companies and get more content and save
money while you're at it go to
expressvpn.com Yang don't forget to use
my link so you can get three extra
months free that's exp r e s s vpn.com
Yang expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
foreign
so you can see problems developing and
your book goes through
city and state failures I suppose I was
gonna say bankruptcies or financial
struggles now a lot of them didn't hit
bankruptcy which you also go into
um so you describe it as a trilemma by
the way is that a real word did you coin
that no no no no no trilemma is a word
that whether it's a real world is it a
weirdo world it's an interesting
question it was um famously coined
famously I say it's famous like this is
Taylor Swift or something
um by two Economist Mandel and Fleming
um to refer to uh trade-offs in the
context of uh of of exchange rates and
Danny Roderick has revived it and to
think about International democracy and
financial flows and so it's been used in
other places but the basic idea I offer
is that if the federal government sees
the state or city in fiscal distress it
has three things it would yeah let's
take a real example so let's say Detroit
which I spent about a lot of time in
um is running out of money Circa 2013
because of a bunch of pension
liabilities and other things I mean
their tax base you know got decimated et
cetera et cetera so then what the heck
do we do continue right so the federal
government has basically three choices
it can offer a bailout and offering a
bailout would help both Detroit's
ability to borrow going forward and help
avoid austerity right now which would be
bad for the economy these things are
generally happen during recessions
um but would create what we call moral
hazard which is that both Detroit's
government and other governments might
grow to extend and really importantly
lenders to those governments might
expect the federal government to come to
their aid every time there's a problem
you could do
um you could force austerity force them
to sell absolutely everything cut
services to the Bone
um and doing that would avoid moral
hazard and would encourage future
lending but would come at the cost of
Social Services to people right now and
also real economic harm because you'd be
firing people during recession and then
finally the other I think is you could
encourage defaults where bankruptcy
um and doing that would
um avoid moral hazard from lending and
would avoid the worst of austerity but
would discourage future investment and
why is discouraging future investment
bad well we rely on states and cities to
build all infrastructure um federal
government is a it's a it's a player
infrastructure but it's a minor player
particularly when you take into
consideration maintenance and operations
costs
um and defaults are are difficult for
that because who wants to lend money if
they're going to lose money and so the
federal government faces this real
trade-off well what are you going to do
about a problem like Detroit
um and over the course of American
History we've done different things so
in the case of Detroit there was both a
kind of a mix of austerity and default
through the bankruptcy process but in
probably the most famous of all these
instances Alexander Hamilton's plan to
assume State debts well that's just a
pure bailout right so States had a lot
of debts they were having trouble paying
the federal government just took their
debts
um and so that was a pure bailout and it
had the effect of creating moral hazard
that is to say British and Dutch lenders
going forward thought that the federal
government would always cover State
debts in fact they thought it after so
the federal state bunch of States
default in the 1840s and then of another
bunch of default in the 1870s but the
British still thought that this was
something the federal government would
cover so when the British owed money to
the federal U.S government in after
World War one they tried to have those
debts offset by money Arkansas had
defaulted which is kind of a funny um
little story so in some situations we've
done bailouts some situations we've done
defaults as I mentioned um and some in a
lot of situations we've done austerity
and we've kind of varied these policies
over time because they're all bad
there's no like one Silver Bullet answer
to what to do about a problem like
Detroit or to do a better Problem Like
New York City in the 1970s or to do a
better problem like Arkansas who
defaults in the 1840s 1870s and 1930s
it's just a series of difficult choices
and you need to figure out how to make
the choices less bad and how to avoid
the problem
going forward so I say in the book that
the one of the central principles about
dealing with state and local debt crisis
is what I call the war games principle
after the movie War Games the uh the
movie War Games ends with a computer
realizing that thermody is it's a funny
game uh the only way to win is not to
play and the best thing the federal
government can do with respect to states
and cities is come up with ways to
sequence the physical problems is to
encourage them to be responsible
um through uh incentives and we can talk
about how they might do so and and also
to come up with ways to minimize the
harms of those of those defaults yeah so
another real life example I like to keep
it concrete for people because uh this
this stuff's gonna get real uh in a
hurry so another one's Puerto Rico which
I've spent a lot of time in and uh
Puerto Rico is not a state
um so it doesn't have some protections
that states have had
and so it it did not get bailed out they
essentially got pushed into bankruptcy
yeah Congress created it was initially
its defensities were found that they
were ineligible for bankruptcy so
Congress had sped the Supreme Court so
Congress had to create a whole new
bankruptcy law effectively they didn't
call it bankruptcy but they uh um it was
it was it was the same same rules as we
apply to things like Detroit
um for Puerto Rico and this had real
effects right so lots of people lent
money to Detroit some of them did so at
well after it was clear that Detroit was
um uh I mean Puerto Rico was um uh not
going to be able to pay there were some
real uh financials there was like
Financial Alchemy is like you know what
I'm gonna lend these guys money and then
I'm gonna get uh it back
my favorite of it is that the um in
Detroit one of their last big borrowings
um they were well beyond their legal
limits for what they could borrow and so
they came up with this jury rig scheme
that um used the some of the same legal
tools that Enron used if it kind of his
Enron declined
um and they were they their special
purpose vehicles and all this weirdo
stuff and um it was pretty obviously uh
not good but uh the the big Municipal
Bond publication the bond buyer gave it
Midwest deal of the year uh after they
did all this the the mayor who had been
the mayor of Detroit went to jail but
not for that so it's one of those things
yeah so so there are and I remember in
Puerto Rico there were just people
taking bets essentially or uh and saying
like well you know I think this debt's
gonna get repriced at this I'll buy it
at this and then then they exerted
political pressure to try and get
um their money back and again that's
been happening forever so in Hamilton's
uh plan to assume State debts one of the
arguments against it was that the then
equivalent of what we can now call
vulture funds had bought up a lot of the
debt and then when the debt gets that
gets paid at 100 cents in the dollar
they bought the debt well below that the
same thing happened in Puerto Rico so
again these are long American stories
um uh but it certainly happened in
Puerto Rico and so Puerto Rico got a
bankruptcy Rule and several interesting
things happened actually I'm a big fan
of legal bankruptcy processes for
jurisdictions
um but they um there's raises some
really difficult questions about like
how much can you expect the government
to cut before you allow it to default
and similarly how do you treat different
class of debtors do you treat pensioners
and bondholders the same way and so
these are really contested issues and
one of the things I like about a legal
process is it puts some constraint on
um kind of the sheer real politique of
the you know pensioners the bondholders
fighting for political attention that
there's at least someone who is at least
somewhat removed from the situation
ensuring that the treatment is not too
unfair so you open your book with a
hypothetical about Chicago and Illinois
becoming insolvent and then the hashtags
which I guess you made up is like uh
Chicago way uh was was one Illinois is
over I think was the other yeah yeah a
little corny maybe but it's yes the idea
you're the social media expert now it's
a um it's the idea to force you to think
about what it is you would do if you
were either a voter in this situation
politicians were doing something or if
you were a politician facing these
questions and they're really difficult
out choices right so if you bail them
out you know I say a senator from Texas
says you absolutely can't bail them out
that would create
um that would create a belief in both
Chicago and other jurisdictions that
they're going to get money forever and
everyone will at the bottom Market will
lend money to these governments for any
any government no matter what form it
takes forever because they know they'll
get bailed down on the other hand like
you could imagine being like well
cutting all the jobs there or raising
taxes will lead to people leaving the
jurisdiction and that's bad and it will
cause a decline in Chicago one of our
great important cities on uh crime will
go up Social Services will go down
that's bad and then if they default well
like who's gonna lend money to
jurisdictions if a Big Rich place like
Chicago or Illinois
um can't make its can't make its
obligation meet its obligations and so
these are really difficult choices and
so I have some ideas about things we
could do to make the problem better but
it's worth thinking about what you would
do because
um I mean one of the things I found
during the covid period is there was a
lot of sense arguing arguing about what
the federal government should be of a
state bankruptcy law should we offer all
of this Aid is it a blue State bailout
is a red State bailout
um and I found that the people talking
about this really didn't take the time
to realize how hard a set of choices
were facing the government it was just a
lot of yelling
foreign
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you
so what's fascinating is I remember
pre-covid in the run-up you look at
cities like New York and Chicago and and
it felt like they were on top of the
world uh and then it seems like things
have very very quickly turned around in
a particular way I I will say like it's
pretty clear that these uh downtowns and
Commercial Office Buildings are going to
take many years to recover if they do
recover uh that if you just expect
everyone to come back because office
culture has changed uh you know like you
ask workers what they want to do and
uniformly they're like hey I like I I
love work from home maybe I'll hybrid it
up and like come in if you force me to
that sort of thing uh and employers
right now are beholden to to their
people and you know you can judge that
in a particular way I certainly know
that if you were a representative of the
city you'd be rooting for everyone to
come back in in full force but it's also
true that a lot of even city employees
like you know or like what am I doing in
this freaking office building so you're
seeing in many ways the value prop of
the city
um get changed and called into question
there have been winners and losers to
this
um certainly some of the winners have
been these uh Sun Belt areas uh where
they have lower uh tax rates and people
can just DeCamp to
um in in various ways so you're you're
going to see many cities struggle uh and
the the danger is that there is like a
like a negative spiral that develops
it's like well okay my tax revenues go
down somebody cut services and then
people are like wait what am I doing
here if like you know like that the
trash can get it picked up or whatnot
two things I think that's really it's
all it's all really really smart um
places like New York have a because
demand is so high to live there even
with a relative decline
um that New York could still attract
people right they allowed more housing
to be built a housing in New York is
still very expensive and do they allow
more housing if there would still be
people who want to live in New York it's
not so clear that's true for some other
downtowns but for New York and for New
York you're seeing like they're still I
mean look at the price of Apartments
they're they're they've decreased
they've they've not increased as much as
outlying areas but the prices are still
really high and that suggests there's
still demand to live in New York
um
but it's certainly less that less I mean
the what what people call the Donut
effect around cities has become true
which is that the outlying areas have
gotten more expensive relatively in
lying areas and this is uh because
people want home offices there's
increased demand for housing people
don't want roommates as much
um and uh you know and people can work
from home and so it's both having
inter-regional effects and then in
Regional effects but like the areas in
Connecticut and even further are doing
very well
um and so that's one story another story
is that um in some ways we should expect
this to uh create a little more
interlocal inequality so one of the
things that was constraining people from
just rich people to just moving near
other rich people is um it's a small
town is that they had to commute you
know you still had to go to the office
um and to the extent you can just go to
Vail or go to you know wherever
um that images Palm Beach right
um that we might expect to see greater
internal interlocal inequality the last
thing I'll say about this I think that
you're kind of pointing towards with the
end of your comments is this one is that
it puts a lot more pressure on cities to
um do better if people have more
residential Choice even if they have
their hybrids they can they have greater
ability to commute further
um it makes cities have to compete along
a different dimension which is they have
to make it nice to live there and so New
York is great to live and I love living
in New York but on the other hand
there's garbage on the streets
everywhere
um and in a more competitive atmosphere
uh you you're gonna have to solve some
of those problems
um you see the kind of cost of this uh
you know the the kind of heavy streak
disorder in San Francisco I think or La
being like a really dramatic instance of
the kind of thing that a greater exit
pressure should will punish
um and so uh hopefully we can get uh
people to focus on cities in their kind
of you know to make them more
competitive uh as places to live and
places to enjoy and not just places to
commute to so you wrote a piece that was
published in the Atlantic recently that
I enjoyed immensely and it ends by
saying hey we don't really pay that much
attention to what's going on in local
government so maybe we should because
it's going to become more important yeah
I mean so the evidence on this is really
really really dramatic and really
interesting so over the last say
increasing over the last 50 years but
particularly in the last 10 and 20 years
um voters have paid less and less
attention to
um particularly legislative elections at
the state and local level so the
evidence of this is that the level of um
split ticket voting or the degree to
which people vote for one kind of
correlation between people's
presidential voting and State
Legislative voting has now reached so
much like it's like in the high 90s of
percentage that almost no one votes for
at different party it's all tribal now
it's not like hey I like this person I
like that person so yeah I like this
team and each each and everyone also
thinks that it's driven by the national
so it's not like people are like I
dislike my state legislature and
therefore I'm gonna punish President
Biden it's the up going the other way
around this is a really really really
negative effect because it's not clear
that anything that happens in the state
of legislature actually matters to who
wins elections right so it's this people
and people don't say literature could do
whatever and it's just not clear that it
has much effect on who wins elections
and so what does matter in those in
those um in those bodies is what the
beliefs of either the extremely
unrepresentative primary voters and or
uh interest groups who are kind of
influenced politics in other ways and so
that has a couple of really negative
effects one is that obviously the
policies are less representative but a
second thing is that it results in
almost certainly results in in more
spending
um and less taxing let's say like less
fiscal responsibility
um because the people who are
participating in the elections are what
political scientists call intense policy
demanders well why would you pay
attention because you want something
or you want to stop something
um and the result of that is that the is
that elections are um these elections
and local elections are pretty
unrepresentative and result in you know
like less than attractive outcomes um
and then you can see this across policy
areas so like what is nimbyism in
housing well one of the reasons we see
it is that um the people who show up in
city council primaries are a deeply
unrepresentative swath of Voters who are
mostly homeowners or people with like
strong strong local interests
um and they don't represent the broader
public and the broader Public's interest
in growth and similarly the groups who
ask for things and participate into
endorsements in these areas can be you
know everything from you know
wanting money a local public local
employee public employee unions all
sorts of people who are perfectly fine
for them to want to be involved in
politics but the absence of mass
politics at the local state and local
level that is to say we're giving tools
to Ordinary People to voice their
preferences through competitive
elections is um a tragedy both for our
budgets and for policy yeah you have a
quote from the book that I enjoyed it
said that is state and local officials
do not seek and do not receive a public
mandate from ordinary voters what
they are instead responsive to narrow
and unrepresentative groups of Voters
and interests uh and that's what you
just described yeah I mean look I mean
you live this and so I don't need to
tell you but we can talk to the audience
you know it's it's that what it is a um
when you start thinking about who how
one gets elected to county commissioner
or state legislator it just doesn't have
very much to do with
doing a good job in office and getting
rewarded for it and in one of the
ironies of course is that National
politics you know works much more like
that and so it is the case that we as
voters generally know what Republicans
and Democrats are all about and like
it's like you know which party is
pro-abortion which party is
anti-abortion it's pretty easy to do um
and so you can punish bad economic
results and there's um some evidence
there's evidence that that has actually
been weaning a little bit but it's still
a real effect
and we see is for new incumbent New York
City Mayors is the one like so when you
have executive officers it's a little
easier for voters to kind of turn them
into Brands themselves and so there's
evidence that when crime rates go up
mayoral popularity goes down in New York
City
um but when crime rates go up people
don't punish their city council numbers
but City Council Members have a lot of
influence on these policies and so when
um transportation doesn't work people
don't punish their state legislators
even though State Legislature is the one
deciding how to fund the MTA or about
policies at the MTA and we like uh
political reform at the state and local
level is really really important it's
important for these budgetary concerns
because again the lack of mass control
results systematically in less
responsible budgeting but it's
responsible for it's a big problem for
lots of other policy areas as well it's
um it's just we're in a deeply unhealthy
time for state and local democracy and
this is driven by a couple of forces one
is the decline of local media yeah on on
uh and there's some really amazing
findings on this like um when a local
paper closes the borrowing costs for the
jurisdictions that a coverage goes up
because you get worse interest rates
because they're like I don't really care
because if you're Lending you're like oh
God these are going to be super corrupt
no one's paying attention why am I gonna
lend the money
um and you see split ticket voting Falls
and so that's your real problem that a
lot of the problem is in voters
themselves that is to say
um these but why isn't there more local
media well some of it is technological
but some of it is that we are addicted
to
um you know the entertainment value of
politics and National politics can be a
little more entertaining
um and so it's incumbent upon people
with a megaphone and to remind people
that these local things have a big
effect on their lives
yes
three quarters of Americans wish they
started investing earlier and over
two-thirds of gen's ears feel the same
way you know why it's tough It's because
it's tricky it's daunting it's
intimidating you know who's started an
app to solve that are the founders of
Bloom Bloom app is the award-winning
Financial Services app it's made by
young people for young people I've met
the founders they are great guys who
want to make you or the people in your
life who are young and just starting out
financially literate check it out at
bloomapp.com and there's a special offer
for listeners to this podcast fifteen
dollars in free stock and one month
subscription for free go to bloomapp.com
Yang to sign up today
bloomapp.com Yang why stay in the dark
in terms of financial literacy let's get
educated people bluemap.com yang
thank you
yeah the the the death of whatever it is
now 3000 newspapers I mean that that
really hurts because how the heck you're
gonna pay attention to what's going on
locally if no one's covering it yeah no
I mean it's interesting I was talking to
these people about this idea they had to
use AI to uh to build local papers out
and like I I don't know whether it's a
good idea or a bad idea but it is um
it's at least responsive to like a real
need to like tell people what to avoid
the vacuum yeah the vacuum right like
tell you a story about a local city
councilman who uh attended meetings and
there was a reporter there and everyone
had their back straight and uh were
buttoned up and then the reporter just
stopped coming probably because they
lost their job and then everyone started
I was trying to laugh but it's terrible
but then and then everyone just started
acting completely differently because
it's like well the you know like the
observer's not in the room and they can
just like oh no no it is it is it is it
is really one of the worst things that's
happened to American democracy I'm a big
fan of something in Congress called the
local Journal some sustainability act
that would Shore up the ability for
local papers to exist and compete at
last I checked I had six sponsors which
means you know a couple hundred away but
but that thing just confused the heck
out of me because like red and blue it's
like you don't want a local paper you
have the sense almost that there are
folks that's like you know I kind of
prefer operating in a journalism free
zone yeah I mean you certainly see that
but you understand why politicians might
want that right so a politician might
want to be in a journalism free zone
because then no one's watching them and
so once they achieve a combat effect
then they'll be fine they can you know
do ads and whatever in New York we have
some green shoots on this front so um I
mean I'm a big fan of the city the
newspaper um which is yeah we have some
some you know it's I mean it's like a
massive market so you have some very
admirable local journalism efforts yeah
and so in Connecticut where I work I am
there's a really wonderful non-profit
called the CT mirror that is probably
the best budget reporting of any state
government state paper in the country I
mean it's not even a paper it's an
online product again again these the
audiences for these things are pretty
small people the the old trick of media
was that people would um you know pick
it up for the sports and for the
classified ads and then get the politics
by kind of an osmosis from it and now
even now like even our people when
people do get papers like they're
getting the New York Times they're the
New York Times just cut it's local
coverage really dramatically
um uh and so they're not getting that
they're they may be focusing on Ukraine
they may be focusing on Wordle yeah but
they're not focused Metro reporting the
Metro desk like the number of
journalists and assigned to that yeah no
it is it is it is wild to me how little
I mean it's just you know it's a it's a
it's how little given I mean the times
particularly is such a financially
successful product and such a successful
product that like they don't feel a
little bit more noblecibly used to cover
New York more
um is is is you know pretty shocking
well so uh I just wanted to hit this a
little bit more so the the for-profit
model of Journalism
um was invented you know when people
figure it out it's like hey I can print
these things I can put ads on it it
lasted until Craigslist so it lasted a
long time I think that this should be
seen as a public good and have more
Public Funding public-private
Partnerships treated as a non-profit
there are a lot of markets that could
sustain a break even paper that was well
run it just can't get stock market type
returns and what's happened was that the
remaining local papers got gobbled up by
various uh Financial players private
Equity Funds and hedge funds and then
just got stripped down uh and and you
know then you just again don't have any
local reporting I mean we have a lot of
unbeliefly rich people in America and
being a newspaper magnate even if it was
a non-profitable new newspaper magnet is
a um great way to achieve like social
Renown and influence and so it's always
been curious to me that you don't see
more of this that like people are happy
to give hundreds of millions of dollars
to put their name on Lincoln Center or
put their name on a public building or
upon University but like in terms of
affecting
both like for good and also for ego like
running a newspaper seems to me to be
like the one of the best things you
could do well I mean you have seen uh
various billionaires pick up
Publications uh but they're more
National to your point yeah they do that
satisfying The Washington Post uh
betting off buying time
um thing things like that on the other
hand I think that there are other things
we could imagine doing
um in addition to helping local media
which again I I support i Sport as well
on uh in terms of uh kind of making some
legal changes to encourage uh a kind of
local party formation
um so one thing I've always liked is the
idea of first of all two things one is
giving Mayors and governors more power
relative to legislators because we have
some idea who they are whereas we don't
know who the local legislator is so we
don't know who's on the city council on
a lot of the thing worries we have are
originally if the mayor's out of control
it can be checked by other layers of
government
um and so stronger Mayors seem to me to
be in a really attractive solution
another thing might be to kind of try to
create like a local party Brands and
some work where the mayor has either the
power or maybe even the responsibility
to endorse candidates for City Council
on the ballot so you can vote for your
Newark you could vote for the Adam slate
or the anti-atom Slate next time you go
for city council
um and that that would be a way of
bringing democracy into these um uh into
these into these elections um you could
even imagine doing that at the primary
level as well I like it uh it it's the
case that 75 of the country now
um is
governed by one party or the other uh
where you know you imagine it's a you
know two-party system it's not really
for most people uh where you have
Democrats running things uh all branches
of government here in New York and then
you go to a place like Missouri to just
be the reverse uh and it's one reason
why I agree with you about this local
party formation is that if you can get
more of that because the minority party
in a lot of these places is something of
a non-factor
yeah it's it's actually a really
interesting thing like one question you
might ask is like why doesn't the local
party the local minority party Rebrand
itself to be different from the National
Party to become more competitive so it's
like why is it that the Republicans in
New York and the Democrats in Missouri
are just like kind of consent to failure
by adopting unpopular positions so like
you're not going to win elections in
Missouri if you are broadly pro-choice
it's just not where the voters are and
so and and similar the opposite is true
in New York
um and there are two real problems with
this one is that even where they do
Rebrand themselves on policy it's not
clear that voters care so the
Massachusetts Republican party uh the
surveys seem to be pretty close to the
median voter certainly Governor Baker
who had been Republican Massachusetts is
a very popular Governor um it's not
clear voters paid any attention one way
or the other Democrats have controlled
the Massachusetts legislature for more
than 100 years but secondly those
parties are governed through book
internal democracy that makes them
pretty unresponsive to the voters so
who's true using their candidates well
its primary voters who are themselves
definitionally in the local minority
um and so that's pretty a pretty
unhealthy you can again you can see
break from this with Executives so Baker
or your Newark example your Bloomberg's
giuliani's or Giuliani before there's so
I'm part of an effort trying to do what
you just described
um in California it's called The Common
Sense party in California and it's meant
to be a counterweight and a choice to
the Democrats because it's as bad not to
have any competition uh so I mean the
good thing about doing it in California
is that you have the top two primary
system so it's um they electorally mean
it possible to do so now it's obviously
going to be a huge challenge right so
voters still associate the Democrats
very positively associated with them so
what you really want to be is like all
Democrats or moderate Democrat or
whatever it is I will say that there's
some frustration with the the Dems in
California so oh for sure I mean
California is going to have some huge
budget problems going forward also you
know um but it's it's definitely the
case that they still win all the
elections right so there's some
frustration but um yeah no it's a it's
an uphill climb I mean I'll actually
give you the numbers so it'll be fun so
um we need 73 000 people to sign up uh
to get party recognition in California
and we're at 32 000 now
um so any California is listening to
this check out ca commonsense.org
um but but that but that is one of the
paths you described yeah you can just
run I mean this is the thing is they can
be Democrats even so we see one of the
things you see in New York is this idea
of confusion where two parties endorse
the same candidate and in New York it
actually doesn't work very well it
doesn't really mean anything people
doesn't don't get a lot of information
from knowing that someone's endorsed by
The Working Families party or Working
Families it doesn't actually provide too
much information my there used to be one
called the marijuana green party which
is now even at the time was a fringe
party and now is a super majoritarian
party I don't even know the real
question is how to create a different
untreated brand in voter's mind that
people will understand that they're part
of the national Democrats
Missouri the opposite of not being
specific but at the same time you're
providing them with information this is
part of a different group a faction
inside the parties
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
what the heck is Helix sleep it is the
mattress of the future company I have
always been someone who valued my sleep
figured you know you're gonna do it for
seven maybe even eight hours you wake up
feeling refreshed and energized what is
that worth Helix sleep can help make
that happen just take their sleep quiz
and figure out what personalized
mattress should be shipped straight to
your door and you have a hundred days to
return it I don't recommend returning it
after 99 days but hey who am I to say
don't take my word for it it's the
number one rated mattress from GQ and
wired can you imagine being the mattress
tester it's a job someone has it Helix
is offering 20 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
right now go to helixsleep.com
yang this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
start it's now
[Music]
okay
I mean what we're doing with Ford is an
attempt to introduce competition and
along the way the the lines you describe
um which is fascinating so you
referenced it earlier we just want to
flesh it out a tiny bit so that you
detail in your book that there are
incentives for a lot of these local
legislators to overspend you know
they're not exactly great at tightening
the belt yeah I mean
normal thing about
preying on our weaknesses voters right
so if you're a legend who wants to Bear
costs if you think that you can spend
money right now get popular cut taxes
right now get popular here's the the one
that really has hurt us David but it's
you know you understand it pension
obligations it's like who really wants
to stand on the other side of and be
like you know what I'm gonna like cut
all your pensions uh you know even
though you've been doing this work for
uh 30 years and you're a sympathetic
group yeah no I mean so this is the
thing and this is part of negotiations
workers and uh public workers have have
accepted a lack of raises in the short
run whichever governments need to uh in
return for these long-run obligations
and the reason that politicians like
giving pensions relative to giving
raises is that again they're kicking the
can down the road and we as a legal
matter should states have what are
called steep we often called State
fiscal constitutions balance budget
rules and limits on debt issuance
um but we don't treat pensional
obligations as debt for the purposes of
those State constitutional obligations
but pensional obligations are just debt
right so you have to pay them there's a
constitutional requirement to pay them
on your and so but we treat them as
preference for the purpose of our legal
regime even if we they're just dead and
this is really really a huge problem so
in the post-2008 period jurisdictions
have this huge Satan local government
this huge huge fiscal problems and they
hid them a lot of them in underfunded
underfunding their pensions and what did
this mean well a lot of the seeds
borrowing capacity let's say the
willingness people had to lend the money
was given away to the underfunded
pensions and the period after 2008 when
interest rates were low and unemployment
was high should have been this period if
this Grand infrastructural Innovation
like that's when you build
infrastructures when when interest rates
are low and when they're available
workers and look back on that period
look at your city and say where is my
grand infrastructure in New York City we
got three subway stops along the Second
Avenue subway that's what we got we
didn't get you know other places in the
world got these amazing Innovations and
we just didn't get it because
jurisdiction weren't budgeting
responsibly and then were hiding their
irresponsibility in pension obligations
I can't imagine elected officials doing
such a thing David I'm kidding so so so
um so you've painted a really compelling
picture
um and the book ends trying to summarize
look when the hits the fan and some
of these places are going to run into
problems and you and I have walked
through some of the reasons why some of
these places are going to run into
problems uh you know you have kicking
obligations down down the road you have
overlying on federal aid that's a
one-time thing uh you might have your
commercial uh tax base uh erode uh you
know some people might be voting with
their feet in various ways so then
starts getting dark uh and then you have
to make the big Choice among the three
options and you lay out some of the the
principles for what one should do so the
three choices to review good fun is
bailout
austerity
or default and I I'm going to like just
give you my personal outlook on this is
that I remember when things were going
bad and I spent time in Detroit when
they were declaring bankruptcy uh they
were they were doing some things where
you're like wow it's rough like they
they have a art collection and they just
sell it to try and meet their
obligations and at the last minute one
of the local philanthropists came in and
bought it because they were about to
like you know have their Art Museum
looted I mean it's pretty you know and
you could look at it and be like well
you know art not so bad but like they're
they're other things um when you're in a
rough time
um it seems like firing more people is
not the best move
um you know like you don't want to add
fuel to a bad fire
um so so to speak I totally understand
the moral hazard issue because it's like
everyone's just like hey but let's just
spend spend spend and then anytime we
get into trouble it's like the bailout
comes
um uh and so it feels like the
um managed process of like a quasi
bankruptcy default
um is like a middle of the road move the
problem then is that lenders get sad and
say you know what I'm not going to give
you guys as much fun as much money uh
now I like that that strikes me as the
least problematic just in the sense that
um like there are a lot of problems why
we have a hard time building
um and I'm sure financing is one issue
but it doesn't strike me as the main
issue it seems like the main issues
around like the over regulation the
layers the complexity the the capture
the corruption probably uh you know like
that that's attended so anyway that that
those are my two cents on the big three
of uh of the bailout austerity and
default so I mean I think my preferences
are take two forms on this I mean so
again I in the book I think the
situation will depend so it'll depend a
little bit which one you prefer
um uh um and so I don't give a single
one answer to rule them all type type uh
type of answer but I think that what you
can do is adopt uh balance Solutions and
then you can add conditions to some of
your support that help avoid problems
going forward so what do I mean by
balance Solutions so things like
bankruptcy but also things like giving
federal aid to both states and cities at
the same time
um can result in um a little default a
little a little austerity and a little
moral hazard and that that has the the
fact that they're small amounts rather
than large amounts there's kind of
declining marginal harms and so in the
Detroit instance the as you know the
philanthropist came through was called
the Grand bargain after bankruptcy they
came through with a bunch of money to
support the art museum but the Steep
which had been kind of holding out and
and not been super friendly to Detroit
also gave a lot of money in matching the
philanthropist money but they did it
after a bankruptcy have been declared
and the result was they didn't create
too much moral hazard because who would
want to go through bankruptcy just to
get fairly that's crazy our state that's
that's crazy on the other hand it
mitigated the harms of the bankruptcies
the pensioners just didn't do that badly
between the philanthropist Aid and the
state aid um they would have done even
better if the federal government offered
a little bit too as President Obama
wanted to do and so this kind of
balanced approach attractive the other
thing I think is really attractive is
that the federal government is going to
give money and realistically it is given
in the last two big crises particularly
during covet it gave an enormous amount
of money it should attach some
conditions to that money in order to
encourage dates to do a little bettering
so what do I mean if the federal money
has said you can get this Federal money
or you can get other streams of federal
money in the state federal government's
giving states and cities money all the
time
um in return though you have to budget
in accordance with a gap with a
generally accepted accounting principles
or you have to accept what Connecticut
put into its Bond the Covenant into its
bonds which are a volatility cap they
put a couple covenants but one was about
which you're getting a one-time amount
of money you have to save a certain
percentage of it and the conditionality
um can help you avoid the problems going
forward so take advantage of the fact
that you're doing something you'd rather
not do which is this Aid
um in return to get some conditionality
and that has two nice effects one is
that the conditions hopefully are good
them films but secondly conditions are
painful and so it makes taking Aid Less
Pleasant than it might otherwise be it's
not a free lunch
um and so one of the things I mean so
the federal aid during covid deceits and
cities was almost certainly too large it
was you know it certainly has helped to
kick off inflation they took a fire hose
out they just went more and like you
know I I got it and now you were saying
hey at least it could have been a
conditional fire hose
and it probably should have been you
know like less of a firehouse Super
Soaker but yeah whatever um but one of
the interesting things one of the
reasons it was so big was because they
were trying to avoid the moral hazard
problems one of them because they give
it to everywhere every place but not
every place had a physical problem but
they just gave money to everybody
um and the um that helps reduce moral
hazard because you're not rewarding a
jurisdiction for Behavior right you
exist here you go but you are just
splashing out the cash
um and of course the jurisdictions that
are physical problem care about it more
so it still creates some moral hazard
anyway the um
they could have done more with this and
they had time to do it not in cares but
in ARP they really did have a chance to
like think this through a little bit
better as far as I'm concerned um to
those are the principles which is I
think they should attempt the federal
government when it's facing one of these
prices it you're gonna bear or make a
bad choice it's gonna be a choice that's
painful but you can build things into it
to make it a balanced bad choice let's
say just a little bad across a number of
dimensions and you can use it to create
situations such that we are
um more um we're less likely to see
these problems going forward and the
last thing I'll say is that we could
probably build the federal system to be
a little more resilient against crazy so
two ways we can make it a little more
resilient and what is one is we could um
encourage places to make it a little
easier to move in and out and so that
would have the effect so right now when
a jurisdiction face the physical crisis
all the rich people leave or all the
poor people can't leave
um because you know
um uh housing costs in other places are
too high I mean so to make it a little
easier to move around the country and I
have some ideas about how to do that
um but the second thing is to um
sometimes this cap code is a left-wing
idea and sometimes it's a coach is a
right wing idea but I'll you know it's
um which is uh we could remove from
States some responsibility for some of
our Cooperative Federal programs in
return for giving them full control over
some other things
um and so uh the big one is like one of
the big problems of state cuts or state
local Cuts during
um during fiscal crises or during
recessions is Medicaid the states and
government co-fund Medicaid
um and
seeds have to cut because they have to
keep a balanced budget during downturns
but that's just when everyone wants
Medicaid right so Medicaid is in demand
when the economy is being and the
federal government can bear that cost
across the business cycle but it's a lot
harder for Cedar City well we know the
next Crisis will come and when it does
come I hope that uh people mind your
book in a bad State responding to State
and local budget crises you know what
the big takeaway here David is uh get
involved in local politics pay attention
because those things matter and uh some
more competition would would benefit us
all I'm 100 with you there um thank you
so much for having me this was really
fun thank you David it was a blast and
uh keep being smart
thank you
[Music]